[Musique]
heureusement dans un cimetière un
cimetière par un cimetière du nord un
cimetière mécanique c'est parti
la première expérience sur bex je peux
pas y pareil d'ailleurs même urbex coup
vraiment pas exactement ce que ça veut
dire moi non plus méchant que ça claque
qu'ils peuvent mais désolé je voudrais
j'ai eu avec vous avez subi
alors urbex c'est un terme qui vient de
urban exploration et c'est une activité
qui consiste à visiter des endroits
abandonné il fait très très chaud là il
fait très très chaud sur 20 c'est
compliqué alors attends quoi
thiès et métro aérien
pour les gens qui ne connaissent pas
vite fais que te contentes de wall e
tanguy j'ai une chaîne soit aux animaux
qui s'appelle tout est donc aujourd'hui
on n'est pas dans le cadre de mes
activités normales mais comme tu es mon
ami jean 80 des dans un endroit
improbable à bangkok
et bah écoute on va aller dans ce
cimetière je pense que tu vas kiffer est
ce que c'est un cimetière paris - non
c'est pas super pour jeter 10 un
cimetière pour la part des choses
mécanique mais pour des cartes
les animaux s'étaient mécanique et bae
poules sont va pas suivre la course est
des cartes
on en reste à peine dix minutes de taxi
[Musique]
j'ai hâte donc là on vient de donner un
bakchich va dire pouvoir entrer dans le
site du cimetière c'est normalement
c'est interdit
je n'ai personne autorisée mais tu peux
être autorisés avec 200 bahts en fait
ici on est sur un terrain vague qui
appartient gros business one thaïlandais
ok on sait pas trop pourquoi et à ces
avions qui sont ici à larache on sait
c'est que tout ce qui avait de la valeur
dans les avions ont déjà été vendus et
qui a une famille qui vit ici
et quand je vois la famille jr et
protège le terrain nous pourrons traiter
obligé de payer tu vois
[Musique]
dans ces conflits
ah ouais
on sait que d'un
[Musique]
on va monter là comment ça le mec fait
l'urbex c'est l'urbex on est des vrais
quoi on aimait les vrais est regardée
nous les gens qui font de l'urbex elle
nous on n'a pas peur hockey et attend il
n'y a pas de serpents et où ouais
j'espère qu'il ya des serpents bordel
d'accord tu étais fier parce qu'il n'y a
rien de ce lieu
oui
ok c'est l'extrême limite mec
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as cru que tu pouvais
faire de leur bec sans prendre de
risques les trucs qu'on éternue en mx2
grand-père avec moi mon truc c'est la
philo hockey aaa
regarde comme c'est où
bon on va aller en exploration et voyez
en fait ce qui est fou c'est qu'ils
restent tous qui ne vaut rien c'est à
dire des bouts de bluetooth qui n'ont
pas pu vendre ils l'ont laissée intacte
et on peut se balader dedans donc c'est
plutôt cool
ah ben on va aller en dessous après away
bas bien sûr qu'on va les voir bien sûr
il ya un trou sombre avec des esprits
maléfiques force par ces mots il restera
or est ok computer
[Musique]
brawl voit la vache on a quelques
défauts techniques ba1 qui va falloir
j'aurais goulard font partie mais le
voile va bien se passer
et reste pas grand chose mais voilà rien
ça c'est la classe de pouvoir actionner
à regarder vous voyez ces tableaux que
vous avez au dessus de vous souvent on
choisit l'aération machin et la lumière
et tout est bien derrière je parle
ensemble à ça l'aération il ya un seul
conduit qui la conduira les trois pour
qu'il a alimenté les trois et ensuite
classique et ses drames et j'avoue que
je n'avais pas calculé que c'était aux
six ans
[Musique]
c'est incroyable
c'est contre la complexité
[Musique]
c'est sûr ouais j'y vais en premier
l'asie se sacrifie toi mec
ok ça c'est dur bex à aller dans ce trou
foireux non je pense que le vrai eurex
c'est chier là dessus je pense que je
pense que ça c'est l'urbex monga cyrus
avant le trou bordel là bas non mais tu
m'as dit que tu as vu un animal j'ai vu
un animal féroce de type félidés en chat
un chat des gens se conclut avec amazon
débat de fond de l'urbex généralement il
faut il pose or ça que je sais pas c'est
quoi le manuel du fonio mec soit chez ba
je suis pas assez urbex au fil pour
savoir mais je trouve que tu as la bonne
dégaine d'un bonheur vexman
[Musique]
le quai
m
[Musique]
sois sage il ya même de l'eau donc là je
pense qu'on est dans les soutes à
bagages
l'état va y aller ici ils ont entreposés
les coffres à les coffres à bagage
cabine
comment on arrive à faire voler ses
[ __ ] de machines ouais même si je
comprends la physique et je comprends
comment ça marche quand tu te rends
compte de la taille du bordel et du
poids je veux bien d'accord jeudi c'est
quand même ouf qu'on arrive à faire
voler ça et pendant
alors imaginons un avion donc il est
soumis à la gravité donc pour qu'il vole
il faut qu'il y ait une force qui le
tire vers le haut
cette force et les plus fortes que la
gravité de l'avion va monter genre c'est
quand ils décollent par exemple et si
cette force est plus faible que la
gravité l'avion va descendre ce dont il
atterrit par exemple pour que cette
force il faut s'assurer que les
molécules d'air qui touche l'avion par
le dessous le fassent de manière plus
forte et plus violente que celle du
dessus la forme de l'elfe etc en
avançant l'avion se prend plus de
molécules d'air par le dessous est plus
fortement
donc la pression sous les ailes de
l'avion augmente et al'inverse il y a
moins de molécules d'air qui se prennent
le haut et moins violemment dû à sa
forme donc la pression est moins forte
au dessus de l'ale
sauf que tout ça ça ralentit l'avion
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya des moteurs
qui pousse l'air ce qui fait que l'avion
avance voilà vous explique sa très
simplement sans vous parler de l'effet
venturi par exemple mais vous pouvez
aller plus loin si ça vous intéresse
chaleur moi je suis en quelque sorte un
bowling le mec souffre montebourg et
thank you think thank you au hockey
par contre le cockpit et trop stylées là
les deux bords en fait sur les petits
avions bouger les pédales ça permet de
tourner l'avion lorsqu'il est au sol par
an pour les gros avions ça permet de
bouger le gouvernail de direction en
gros quand le pilote il veut tourner à
gauche
nous dépensons manche il va à gauche ce
qui se passe c'est que les ailerons vont
bouger
ok sur l'ailé gauche ils vont bouger de
sorte à ce qu'ils aient moins de
portance du couple elle va descendre et
sur l'ailé droite ils vont bouger de
sorte à ce qu'ils aient plus de portance
donc là elle va monter sauf que s'il ya
plus de portance et aussi plus de
résistance de l'air donc l'avion il va
un petit peu piqué comme ça vers la
droite est bien le gouvernail de
direction ça permet de redresser la
trajectoire
[Musique]
vim
des gens c'est le réservoir
je suis là enfin moi ce qui me surprend
c'est à quel point tout ça c'est
mécanique de ouf genre air dont 10 à
plus tard ce que tu fais à partir
incroyable non mais genre là le câble
est où là complètement bouger un câble
et là ça va bouger c'est un tout c'est
ouf car le volant par exemple ça tire le
mien c'est un gros bordel hyper
mécanique en fait c'est pas c'est
beaucoup moins électronique penser en
même temps je pense que cet avion il
date un peu
j'ai aucune idée du modèle ça par contre
c'est hyper stylé c'est ce truc là je
connais vraiment un missile quoi
exactement
et ça c'est quand du coup le pilote il a
pas assez d'argent pour la garderie et
est même surnommé lui file un petit
boulot pour faire joujou quoi
maintenant si on bat pour ces petites
choses qui étaient dans le cockpit c'est
assez chaud trouver des infos du coup
j'ai contacté un pilote en ligne qui
n'est autre que captain jo qui a été
hyper sympa parce qu'il m'a répondu m'a
laissé une note vocale trop sympa
vraiment merci beaucoup et d'ailleurs
n'essaie pas le suivre si vous qui fait
ce genre de chose de ce qui me dit le
petit volant là c'est pour conduire
l'avion au sol
ce serait un string kraft ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle des gras du death watch
donc des boutons à bascule sous cash
je n'ai pas trouvé de meilleure
traduction en gros c'est pour des trucs
qui sont assez importants et qu'il faut
pas enclenché sans faire exprès jean par
exemple des procédures d'urgence
et ça c'est un voilà c'est à dire un
compensateur
je vous mets un lien wikipedia si vous
voulez aller plus loin tout ça c'est en
description de la vidéo évidemment
encore marcher à captain jo et je vous
laisse avec la suite de la vidéo
aujourd'hui
faire à peu près sans exagérer il doit
faire quoi 32 34 degrés 24 des bâtiments
fouet je pense doit faire 34° à peu près
on est en plein soleil comme du rabbi 44
ha long mais a pas l'ombre
tu as le mexique duby chantait pas du
tout adapté ryumbeke ce [ __ ] mais qu
il ya donc six qui est passée par là
incroyable c'est ça leur bec ce mec
c'est une égratignure compte c'était ça
j'ai passé mon pied dans le trou l'a
d'abord une belle cicatrice je vais
garder une belle cicatrice thème voit
les jolis quoi le lé style et sa la tête
en guise et décomptés mais je crois
qu'on fait partie du club des mecs qui
font globex
ça y est ça y est je pense que cette
première vidéo nordex de ma chaîne
écoute première vidéo l'urbex de ma vie
tu vois de ma vie c'était cool enfin
balance est hyper cool
superbe et puis c'est tout en plombant
cox et culpa next et chant et merci
d'avoir fait des coiffes mais avec
plaisir franchement j'aime voyager qui
fait amener ici c'était vraiment cool et
tout ça me fait plaisir que tu kiffes tu
vois déjà ça m'a fait plaisir de voir
ici à bangkok
tu vois ça s'est fait plaisir
vous voulez plus dur bex allez voir ça
n'allait pas avoir la même vous ne
retrouverez pas j'ai un peu d'animaux
même beaucoup d'animaux exactement
arrivé à ma chaîne tout pète et attend
mec t'as oublié dire un truc abonnez
vous et surtout si c'est un truc qui
vous a plu et c'est même si ça sort
totalement de ce que je fais d'habitude
n'hésitez pas à me dire en commentaire
si vous en avez pensé que c'est toujours
un plaisir de tenter des trucs sphère
qui fait sur cette chaîne puisque le but
avant tout c'est ça c'est qui fait c'est
très grave
ciao ciao
[Musique]
ok je te dois posséder le lurex